selling organs is illegal in India but
there's a thriving black market that
takes advantage of a loophole in the law
these so-called donor transactions are
run by a shady network of back-alley
brokers corrupt officials doctors and
organized crime a network that takes
advantage of people like Malika
in debt she needed money um she gets in
touch with a man who is said to be able
to help people
I didn't do that his name was Raji he
lived near my house I asked his wife why
all these people kept coming to their
house and she said they give kidneys and
if they give kidneys they get money
three and a half thousand dollars lured
in by the money she agrees to the deal
Raji and another man begin taking Malika
on trips shopping her around my loved
one they took me to my lover and they
did blood and urine tests from one
hospital to the next Raji looks for the
best price
money in the wild well we were put in a
hotel room and they instructed us to
stay there and not to talk to anyone
Caitlin well they gave us one day to
rest Marty I was told I would get the
money when the operation was complete 24
hours later her kidney is extracted
she's told it's been transplanted into
the son of a wealthy foreigner foreigner
who likely paid some $40,000 for the
kidney after the surgery Malika gets
only $700 less than a fifth of what she
said she was promised tens of thousands
of dollars heating up
by brokers and middlemen you need to
because Allah he said I don't have the
rest of your money they're not in a pond
where me and what at anything and even
if I do not give you the money what
could you possibly do to me I'm getting
given the gate and you guys see more
clearly then we're gonna be paid
Mollica persists and the brokers begin
sending her death threats and then they
vanish
what
through a tip with tracked one of the
men named Raji to the fishing docks in
the harbour where he and his wife run a
small shop so the kidney broker is now
refusing to talk to us and the wife is
vehement so we're gonna see if they'll
come meet us in private I think yeah
much to our surprise
two days later Raji agrees to an
interview how did you become a broker
yeah
at first he denies he's a broker or that
he even knows Malika then his story
changes she came to my house two or
three times and asked me to arrange the
deal he admits to brokering the deal and
I started to ask questions about how the
network operates
I don't know about that the doctors
operate and send their bill where does
all the money go
nobody's getting cheated everyone gets
exactly what they're promised
about Mollica share of the deal she got
what she deserved I told her it was
40,000 rupees and she accepted
now she waits three years to complain
the interview starts to fall apart and
he becomes evasive with Rajee the
underground trail dead ends